LLR JOINING .
I'M FREDRICKA WHITFIELD.
EASTN E ON THISU 11:00 A.M
OF
HOUS TROPICS STRE.IAN ISXPTONDY
WE'RPECTINE FROM MIOW THE EC AS
PRA ALVAREZ
PRESIN
LMGY
NATIONS WHATE LEARNING.
NED WINDS E AT0 PEO .EM
4 O WEST-NTH
ANWE HAV
SOMEF S IS W
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE WATCHES
ANRN
ICE NG TO SESO OOU S
THOSE TRANTION INT
WE DO ST FORGRAND ANT WE'RSEEIN.
ASON IS THNSIFICATION.
ICATTO TO GE
OF EXPECTE BE TO  FEET.AST
SIGCAE FOR  AOUTHAT I STRENGTHY
TONIGHT.
THEN STRENN EVEN FURTHER A
IT MAKES I AS
TOWARDS FLORIDA AST MAKES ITS T.
QU ERY
WHT GOING AND WHEN IS IT
AKE LAFA
LEM IS VLIH INGS.
THE AMERICANELS CALLR LANDFALL A
MORNING IS MA LD WEDNESDAY EVES
GOING E OF IGFI ONES WITH
THIS S, DD
API OF
O
IS FOR THAY RATHATL TE
E WE DO KNOW
SO G TO H
TY NARROWED DOWNDNESDAARE GOINGE
TOE NEXT 4URNKOU
UPDATE
YOW MIGHT THIS STORM IAC
S ATTE RALLYE PLANS NO E OF THE.
STATE  FLODA, BIDEN EMERGENCLARN
A  IS
R  F
FRED?EENITORIN NOWEAD FECES FOR.
IG OLET'G  N FEMA'ADBANK.
D TO
TO GET
AHEAHIS STOR
>> THANK YCKSO
AS YOU S
WAS REQUESTEOVAL O
NOW QUKL IN, N OIALIZED  IE
ANNGIG
THE GULFIDOFLORIDA OEN
>>AST WION UOV I E NOW. YOUR EV.
Y PREPARED BOUTPETS
GEONARSSFOOD,  BAT
LNSURAN CUMENTOFM, SO IFTHERE
RENGERFOLKS DIDEPENDANT.
WE WAN THAT IFDIDEPENDANT, DA
DIVISION OF EMERGENCD E  NEE
HAVEICIO
IMPORTANT.
NG
G WITHM TO T
MOST VULNERA WE WE
ES OF IN
FO.UNOARNO
BECAUSE OF?TAINLYITRT
PREPARE AND ECUR
O.ONIENDS, YOUR NETWORNSU'RE O
NOT ONLY TO SUPPORT THPHYSICAL
EM
THIES THATEN IMPACTE STORMS INHE
THS THE TIME FORRESOURCES TO TR
THAND WATER
D COMMOD
IF YOUEDT, YOUD TOL OSCHK GEWH
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOU
T OUT TW
THIS ATLANTRRAN
>>
THROUGASONWE WANTRESS CAOFFICIS
TAKE EVACUATION DERIOU